thanks Anna thanks for having me back
you know I always love coming here and
doing these presentations you know it
was great that you just had
Peter on because Peter is also an order
flow trader
and educator and you know there's a lot
of overlap being between his type of
order flow and my type of order flow you
know reading what comes into the market
and trading it and basically what I want
to talk about today is show you how to
use order flow to recognize you know the
bad trades so you don't take them or get
out of trades earlier you know one of
the things that every trading book out
there talks about is you know cutting
your losses short right everyone says
you know to be successful you know you
got to be able to last in the business
and the way you last in the business is
by you know cutting losses as as close
as you can to break even and keeping
them small and let your winners run but
you know in theory it sounds great but
the practicality is you know most people
don't do that
you know most people have this mentality
of you know I'm just gonna let the trade
you know I have a signal it says buy or
sell and I'm going to take it and we go
down with the ship is gonna go to my
take profit or it's going to go to my
stop and you know all too often a lot of
people end up losing more money by
getting stopped out on trades that they
could have got out earlier so my goal
for you guys today is what I'm going to
show you how to use order flow to manage
your trades so you can see what's
happening in the market and make that
decision you know should I get out of
this trade or is this trade gonna have a
higher chance of success and also I'm
going to show you how to use order flow
to stay out of bad trades before you
take them now imagine you know at the
end of the year right you look at your
trading results and you see that okay
you know I had you know six hundred and
fifty trades for the year and yeah
you're sort of you know a 50% hitter
right here you're going about you know
plus you know 325 winners 325 losers you
know if that was exactly 50% but what if
you can automatically take out you know
say just 50
of those losing trades you know so
instead of having 650 trades you only
end up with 600 trades but you removed
50 of the losing trades you know you end
up with a much higher trading percentage
but more importantly you end up with
more winners than losers so if you stick
around to the end you know for those
that are new to me you know give you a
link that you could go and download my
book on trading order flow it's a 150
page book that I wrote on trading order
flow so you know for those that are
brand-new to me today you know just a
little bit about myself you know I've
been in the trading industry for 25
years you know the last four years I've
been with the order flows the company
that I started but prior to that and I
spent eight years at JPMorgan as vice
president of Futures Trading you know on
the trading desk trading I spent three
years at Commerce Bank I was the license
Eurex trader in Chicago you know
Commerce Bank couldn't trade buns Bob
Welsh at Stax anything without me being
there at commerce panic I had the
license you know I was the member with
the exchange I spent four years at
Cargill you know it's the largest
privately held firm in the United States
and you know the big commodity traders
you know they traded everything you
could imagine not just futures they'd
trade in the cash they trade forwards
they trade spot everything anything you
know salt they trade shipping contracts
they trade everything you could imagine
prior to that was with the English
trading company ETF man that's been
around since the 1700s
you know big sugar traders that's what
they were famous for and I started on
the seamy floor back in the 90s you know
I literally started at the bottom of the
industry and worked my way up all the
way up to JP Morgan you know I started
as a runner
I made what was it like five dollars and
25 cents an hour or something and you
know it just I like doing these
presentations because now there is no
trading floor where you can get access
to traders and you know talk to traders
you know it's very difficult to talk to
successful traders nowadays you know
they're successful traders you know
trade for a hedge fund and you just
can't approach them and being on the
trading floor you know exposed to many
different trading styles long term short
anything you could imagine you know
people were trying to make money on the
trading floor trading that method so you
know after I left JPMorgan I was trading
an order flow from my own account you
know I started writing my book and I was
using order flow software actually from
another company but all the order flow
software that was available at the time
which is basic it was just a format in
the data into a footprint chart and if
you're familiar with software right you
know that it exists to help make your
life easier to help you do things help
you analyze things and so I wanted order
flow software that's going to help me do
the analysis I was already doing in my
head and by hand and you know it took
about six months to really get what I
wanted done I had a nice programmer who
understood order flow you know that's
very important a lot of these
programmers nowadays you know they don't
understand order flow and you know
they're trying to make tools to help
traders and they're just copying stuff
right they don't have anything original
you know Peter pointed this out you know
it's just you know there's so much
software out there now that you know you
don't really understand what you're
getting especially if you're new to
order flow that's why I talked about my
background so you can understand what
the order flow is software that I have
does and I'm not gonna really talk about
my software here today but if you're
interested just go to order flows
dot-com you know a lot of people you
know have positive comments you know the
software people that understand trading
and have adapted order flow you know
just find it just makes trading much
more easier you know here's a comment
someone posted on Facebook a while back
you know the software really helps them
see what's happening in the market you
know for example who's in control and
who's not now what I'm presenting is
what I based my own trading on right
this is what I did for 20 years at a
very high level this is what I did to
earn money to pay my bills you know pay
my house pay my car pay for food
everything you know I didn't trade you
know as a hobby you know that's what I
did for a living and hopefully you can
pick up some nuggets that you could
apply to your own trading and you know
if you can't apply exactly what I teach
maybe you could modify it to help you in
your trading
now I'm not saying that you have to say
do what I say just because I say it now
you have to evaluate it you know and
decide if it's going to hell
you and if not reject it now before I
begin just you know brief disclaimer
don't trade with money you can't afford
to lose you know it's very difficult to
be successful trader if you're under a
lot of stress now I've worked with a lot
of professional traders I've worked with
a lot of retail traders and you know I
always like to see what's working for
people or what's not working for people
why do people fail you know that always
fascinates me you know you go to these
message boards you know most failed
traders spend a lot of time on message
boards complaining about stuff this
doesn't work professional traders just
trade and there's a big difference and
one of the reasons I've noticed you know
you could just go read people's journals
that they post online and the number one
reason why people fail is they take bad
trades you know it's simple you know if
you want to improve your trading the
easiest way to do it is simple is don't
stay in bad trades you know we've we've
it's just like dating right you know if
you're in a bad relationship with
somebody you cut the relationship you go
on there's other fish in the sea
there'll be other trades to happen you
know when you get into a trade it's like
playing cards right you're dealt a hand
of cards you can only play what you're
dealt
now in poker that's a game if you got
bad cards you can fold right in trading
all you have to do is you get out of the
trade and you wait for a better hand you
wait for better opportunities you know
what looked like a good opportunity
right now maybe 10 seconds later looks
completely the opposite because you know
there's order flow coming in you know
you may sit here you know all the
planets may be aligned you know and
everything all the trendline is perfect
you take the trade but you know what
there's a program out there you know
goldman sachs has a program to do you
know you just got long goldman sachs
algo says to get short goldman sachs
comes in and sells 5,000 d minis even
though everything on your indicators
tells you to buy well if goldman sachs
starts selling a ton of em in ease your
trades probably not gonna work out your
probably gonna get stopped out are you
gonna take the loss and you know you
have to realize that you have that's
where reading the order flow comes
in a hand is because you can see what's
happening in the market and make a
decision okay his trade is not working
out as I expected I better get out so
you know any card game that you play you
know you get an ace you're sitting
pretty whether you're playing poker
blackjack or war go fish you get an ace
you're happy right and the thing is in
any game though you're Delta an ace you
know any card game your guys you have a
good hand right if you have a bad hand
if your Delta 2 or a 3 I think oh my
gosh you know I got a bad hand I'm
probably not gonna win this hand so it's
like trading right you get into a trade
and you got a week and in the market
even though you're in the trade well the
market gives you the opportunity to get
out of it by cutting it you know that's
where you could that's where everyone
talks about cut your losses short you
got a bad hand ok you got into the
position it's not really working out
it's not doing what you expected you cut
it that's what people talk about when
they say cut your losses short so you
know if you have a trade setup you like
and you get into the trade you manage
the trade by watching the order flow but
people say well how do I do that you
know I don't know what to look for in
the market well you have to look at the
order flow you have to look yet how the
orders are coming in after you get into
the trade right now with the order flow
I've narrowed it down to three building
blocks you know that these are the three
things that every trader needs to know
about trading with order flow it's Delta
it's point of control and it's
imbalances these are the three building
blocks that everything about order flow
is built on once you understand these
three concepts then you're going to
understand what's happening in the
market now every bar is going to have a
delta every bar is going to have a point
of control every not every bar is going
to have an imbalance but maybe half of
them will and that's very important
information this is market generated
information now just really quick Delta
is the net difference in a bar between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
and you know most software this is my
software this chart here Delta
appears on the bottom if it's positive
Delta generally it means buyers are in
control that's negative Delta a negative
number then it means sellers are in
control okay
now the point of control each bar has a
point of control it's the price level in
a bar where the most volume traded okay
and generally as the market is moving up
pointer controls are going to be
migrating higher if a market is moving
down subsequent pointer controls are
going to appear lower than the previous
one and these can act as supply or
demand as ice I should change that to
support a resistance rather over the
next bar or bars you know people always
wonder why the next bar comes start
sprinting and trades back to a certain
level in the previous bar oftentimes it
trades right back to that point of
control in the previous bar and just
imagine you know that information having
knowing in the next bar where the market
could pull back to you know that's
information even if it doesn't do it a
hundred percent of the time if it just
does it fifty percent of the time which
is about what it does with order flow
maybe a little bit less you know you can
build a trading plan around that and you
could help analyze what's happening in
the market now imbalances again not
every bar is going to have an imbalance
but you got to remember right and
imbalance sorry the markets trade in a
two-way auction there's a bid there's an
offer and when the volume that was
traded on the bid against the volume
traded on the offer is over a certain
amount you know industry standard is
about four to one Peter just mentioned
he uses about two to one but his
analysis is a bit different you know and
what he's really looking at and it's
what I'm looking at is where the
imbalances are appearing in the market
and on an uptrend you're gonna see
buying imbalances on a market moving
down you're gonna see selling it
balances why is because you're gonna be
having an aggressive sellers as the
markets moving down causing selling
imbalances
you're gonna have buying imbalances as
the markets moving up because you have
aggressive buyers actively lifting the
offers thinking this price is good price
I'm gonna buy it I'm gonna buy the next
price I'm gonna buy the next price you
know they're happy to take the market
they're being aggressive in moving the
market you know those are what
imbalances are and once you start
understanding the relationships between
the buyers and sellers at a price level
then you can understand the market
better right now you know the the
problem with a lot of traders again this
is why I'm doing this presentation is
because you know I want you to
understand you don't have to go all-in
on every single trade right you can just
you know feel the water you know get
into the trade is the market doing what
you expect it to do watch the order flow
you have to manage the trade you know a
lot of traders think that oh my god I
just bought a system
I bought a method that says you know if
it prints blue you buy but prints red
you sell well yeah sometimes it'll work
sometimes it won't work what if you can
eliminate the times it doesn't work and
takes the full loss if you could just
minimize that to you know a few ticks
and then let the winners just take care
of themselves where do you think you're
going to be at the end of the day you're
probably going to be ahead of everybody
else so again you know I just talked
about the three concepts of order floors
you know Delta point control and
imbalances that's what you're gonna look
at in the order flow once you get into a
trade to manage their trade okay so
let's take you through a couple examples
a couple walkthroughs you know this is
where the power of order flow really
comes in you know it's market generated
information right and it's a bit like
reading a book reading a story you know
the market is telling a story on what
buyers and sellers are doing you know I
have a buy signal here okay doesn't
matter whether you're using you know an
order flow indicator or you know some
indicator you just bought off you know
your buddy or someone you bought off
Facebook or wherever doesn't matter what
matters is you got into a trade what's
happening after the trade happens you
know is there complimentary order flow
is there order flow telling you that you
know you got long is there buying coming
in you want to see buying market is not
going to go up just because you bought
it right you need other people to have a
reason to buy also
so here this is bar one ground zero
right I have my signal I have my stop
level so I'm ready to get long I get
long okay
next bar it's kind of mixed you know
it's got negative Delta it's gotten
minus five as the Delta the bar opened
and closed at the same level okay I got
a couple buying imbalances yeah okay you
know it's it's not the worst bar that
you could have after you got long but
you know it's not looking good because
it's kind of a smallish bar you know you
can get long you expect the market to
take off you don't expect the market to
start going sideways the next bar after
that what happens you got a red candle
well the markets not going up all right
it's going down you got a lower point of
control than the previous bar that's
also a bearish sign Delta is small it's
one it's positive one which you know is
could be zero you know it's kind of
neutral in that sense so you know I'm
not seeing a lot of bullish activity at
this point I'm in the trade I'm
underwater already and thinking you know
this is where you got to start you know
being proactive in your trading you know
do I stay in this trade or not you know
you're ready to bars into this and
you're already losing money
okay wait for the next bar alright next
bar comes in another down candle the
point control is higher okay it's a
little bit good but you got negative
Delta the markets still not moving
higher still hasn't gone higher then you
know the second bar after you know the
signal bar so it's just going sideways
at this point and you got negative Delta
where is the aggressive buying coming in
you know you don't see a nice positive
Delta you know then you take it over the
next bar trades down point of control is
lower you see a selling imbalance you
see a buying imbalance but you see
negative Delta you're not seeing what
you want to see in the order flow you're
not seeing higher points of controls in
each bar
you're not seeing positive Delta coming
in you're not seeing a lot of buying
imbalances you know you're buying
imbalances you had to write after the
signal bar but that was it next bar
comes in another red candle you know
this market just can't go anywhere it to
be honest buy this bar if you're
not out of this trade already you you
really ought to be getting out because
this is at the point you're gonna be
sitting around thinking oh well I know
my stop levels here I'll just let it go
to my stop take me out no you got to get
out save yourself save yourself five
ticks you know why should you take the
full loss of you know ten ticks when you
could cut it smaller this is what it's
talking about when people say cut your
losses short this is how you people
think well I'll just have a tight stop
that's gonna cut my losses short you got
to manage the trade right so at this
point in another you got three pointed
controls all going down three bars with
all negative to us you got four bars
with negative Delta one with positive
Delta of just one which is might as well
just be zero obviously you got red
candles three red candles going down
it's not looking good all right next bar
a small green candle still negative
Delta they're still selling going on
here right you're ending up these bars
with negative Delta that's not a good
sign now this is an area where a lot of
traders get stuck this is you know
something I've noticed over and over a
lot of traders see this bar this bar
number eight starts turning up it's a
green candle you got a higher point of
control you got a couple buying
imbalances that towards the top of that
bar and you got a positive Delta they're
thinking well this is it I sat through
all this junk in here the last six bars
last five minutes market going sideways
now it's gonna turn around and start
making its move this is where a lot of
traders get caught because what happens
oftentimes the market should have moved
already you're so far away from what was
happening on your indicator on in this
case this is my market exhaustion
indicator that is bullish for the market
well the markets not making that move
and you're just spending more time going
sideways the reason for their trade has
deteriorated over time people don't
realize that you know think of it you
know as a hedge fund trader right you're
a macro trader you trade fundamentals
and you have a trading decision all
right your your trades you last for you
months or years right imagine instead of
a one-minute chart you're looking at
weekly charts the guy takes a trade you
know he thinks the price of cattle is
going up because
you know some cattle disease but then
the market doesn't go anywhere right
maybe there's something out maybe
they've found a cure for hoof-and-mouth
disease that the price isn't gonna go
higher anymore in this time you know
Carol's being vaccine is being cured
well you know that's new information
that's coming in just as you know with
the order flow in in a very micro sense
here I'm looking at a one minute chart
you know there's stuff coming in in the
order flow people's minds are changing
since the signal was generated because
you're not getting that complimentary
order flow the follow through buying in
this case since you know it was a long
signal it's just not there you're
already seven bars eight bars from the
signal bar and then market starts poking
a little bit higher and this is it
there's a lot of people they take a lot
of heat on trades thinking this is it
markets gonna start making a the 50 tick
move and then what happens instead of
getting out when they had the chance to
get out at a small loss or a break-even
boom just enough to keep sucking them in
there the sellers come in and boom stops
them out all right whatever support was
there is now gone and the sellers have
taken over right because imagine what's
happening in here is you do have some
support of buying all right you're going
sideways there's you know potential
absorption going on well once you remove
that absorption what's going to happen
to the market it's gonna drop the bottom
is gonna fall out right and then
eventually you know you just get stopped
out you know Kenny Rogers had the great
song the gambler and I don't like these
gambling analogies and training but you
know this is actually a more of a life
analogy you gotta know when to hold them
no one to fold them no one to walk away
no one to run you know whether it's
trading where there's playing cards or
whether it's dating somebody you know
you got to realize when things are not
working out you know we all love the
trades that our textbook examples you
know you get your buy signal then the
market just boom makes the moonshot go
straight up right after you buy it or
right after you sell it well market just
sells off immediately hits your profit
target within the next one or two bars
you know those are the great trades but
not all trades are going to be like that
you're gonna have these trades where the
market just goes sideways on you you
just get stuck you get caught off you
know you get caught in these little
traps and then the mark
it sells off cake you know I always say
the market gives you an opportunity to
get out at a small loss or break even
before it goes to the full loss so
here's another example just walk through
this one really quick as well you got
your buy signal right you get long okay
yeah I got nice positive Delta I've got
the bar turning up I got buying
imbalances in there everything is
looking great okay
get long well next part comes in hey
this is great trades starting to work
out you know next bar is up I got behind
in balance but what do I got in here I
got well I got small negative Delta okay
no need to panic yet you know it's still
looking okay you know I'm not negative
on this you know just because I got a
small negative Delta doesn't mean it's
it's the end of anything you know I
could read that as being some support of
mine coming into the market and I'm in
the money okay but I gotta see what's
gonna happen next next bar doesn't go
any higher turns around lower point of
control Delta is positive positive 17
okay that's that's a decent sign it's
got a buying imbalance in the body of
the bar okay
well you know it's starting giving me
mixed signals right
I want this next bar I want the market
to be going higher not sideways on me
you know this bar is it's almost an
inside bar but you know that's that's
not a good sign you know then in the
fourth bar what do I got I got negative
Delta minus 40 I got five selling
imbalances in this bar I've even got a
stack selling a balance in there I got a
lower point of control a lower high
lower low you know this is not what I
want to be seeing I want to be seeing
higher high higher low I wanna be seen
buying imbalances I want to be seeing
positive Delta I'm already three bars
into this trade and you know I'm sitting
on a small loss that's not what I want
to see after being in the trade after
three bars have already printed you know
you want to be going higher not lower
next bar even lower another down candle
another negative Delta another
lower point of control selling and
balance down there at the bottom you
know it's not looking good you know I
have my stop level down here and I'm
trading about you know six ticks above
the stop level you know this is at this
point I got to start thinking I gotta
turn mother's picture to the wall and
get out of here right there's no harm in
taking the loss when all the order flow
that's come in after you got long is
negative next bar turns up again this is
where this is the market giving you the
opportunity to cover it yeah you got
stack buying and balance you got total
of four buying imbalances in their you
can ice positive Delta you know green
candle looking good higher point of
control okay you know this is your
opportunity if you didn't get out at the
end of this bar this is your opportunity
to potentially get out now you know
because if you don't what's gonna happen
over the next several bars you just
could get more of the same down candle
up candle down candle before it finally
pokes down and and goes to your stop
level and stops you out you know you why
take the full loss when you could got
out at a half a loss okay so you know
that's how you can manage your trade
with order flow you know by
understanding when a trade is not
working as expected you got the
opportunity to cut it cut it early
rather than letting it and go to you
know your full stop and taking their
full loss you know it's like you know we
all have cars right you know you got to
take your car in for service and your
reason you do that is so it stays good
you know that you know waiting for all
the the red lights to start flashing is
is not the time you want to be doing it
because the cars probably gonna break
down you know you got to manage your car
you got to maintain your car just like
with the trade right you got to maintain
you know the trade so we're going to
show you next is really the meat and
potatoes here's is how to use order flow
to stay out of bad trades before taking
them right like I was talking to earlier
about this is you know if you can remove
a certain percentage of the trades that
are most likely going to fail you may
honestly you may remove a couple that
are going to be a winner
but if overall you're removing the
trades that are going to fail
overwhelmingly you
better off removing that whole set and
you know it's not a topic that's really
discussed at all I call it entry
execution it's more of an advanced topic
on training but no one really talks
about it you know and one of my bosses
my boss said EDF man you know after I
had a very bad trade you know he's kind
of being facetious and sarcastic and but
giving me a little mr. Miyagi moment at
the same time is you know he saw I was
kind of upset about this trade that I
took that lost money and he's like I'll
give you a tip don't lose money okay and
then I was for like a week after I'm
like what the hell is he talking about
don't lose money of course I don't want
to lose money what he meant is stay out
of those trades that are going to lose
money I was until afterwards that I
really understood what he was talking
about and you know even Peter just
touched on it on his presentation is you
know everyone is so indicator based you
know the red light green light you know
there's a buy signal you take it there's
a sell signal you take it that's not
trading right like you said you know you
get a Goldman Sachs JP Morgan to get a
monkey to trade oh actually they'll get
a computer to trade it well you get a
monkey to sit behind the desk and just
eat bananas and make sure the computer
doesn't get you know touched but the way
I use order flow and the way I prefer
people to use order flow is to watch
what's happening after they get a signal
you could either take the trade
immediately or give the trade a chance
to work you know if you get that
complimentary order flow coming in
that's when you take the trade you know
would you rather miss a trade and not
take a full loss or take a trade give up
one or two ticks because you got in a
trade you know a bar later two bars
later you know give up a couple of extra
ticks rather than giving up a bunch of
ticks okay and when you're using order
flow to find trades after you find the
trade wait for the complimentary order
flow to appear or rather don't wait you
know read the order flow and understand
what's happening because that's real
where the benefit in order flow is
understanding what's happening in the
market
so if you're buying you want to see
buying order flow coming into the market
after you bought you know if your seller
you want to see selling order flow
coming in after you're sold all right
the markets not gonna move just because
of you
right just because you bought it's not
gonna go up just cause you sold it's not
gonna go down
you know you need everybody else to be
doing the same thing so what are you
gonna be looking specifically for in the
order flow well if you're long you're
gonna be looking for price movement in
the direction of your trade obviously
right you gonna be looking for the
market to go up markets going down after
you bought chances are it's gonna keep
going down you don't look for positive
Delta I can look for higher points of
controls you're gonna look for buying
imbalances you know if you're short
first thing you look for obviously is
price movement in the direction of your
trade you want the market be moving down
not up
if you're short negative Delta you're
gonna want to see address of sellers you
gonna see lower point of control you
don't want to be seen the value area of
the bars migrating lower and you want to
see a selling imbalances right you want
to see aggressive sellers coming in and
taking out price levels now where do you
want to see it well you want to see it
happening in the next bar or tool you
know yeah could be waiting for ten bars
for confirmation you know if you don't
get the confirmation immediately trades
probably not gonna work out right if
it's not there don't take the trade you
know the markets have been here for a
hundred two hundred years almost it's
gonna be here for a lot longer so if you
miss a trade there's no e plenty of
trading opportunities and depending on
the type of chart you're trading
whether it's a one-minute chart
five-minute chart you're gonna get
multiple opportunities throughout the
day you know I know people are trade on
30-second charts 15-second charts you
know it just really depends on you
simple right you get to an intersection
red light green light for the traffic
the stop sign you know that don't walk
the walk sign just because there's a
walk sign you don't just immediately
start walking you look to the left you
look to the right then you start walking
once everything is clear you go and it
should be the same way when you are
trading you know when everything is
clear in the market that it's going in
your direction that's your time to take
the trade you go right so I'll just take
you through some more
examples he could understand what I'm
getting at here you know so here's a buy
signal right okay what I'm saying is
don't get long immediately you know this
is you know people get excited I got a
buy signal I gotta get long you know my
indicator says to buy it I gotta buy it
well if you buy it okay what happens to
the next bar you know it's got negative
Delta
it's got selling imbalance you know it's
a down candle pointing controls at the
same level it's not looking good okay
but if you don't buy it because you're
waiting to see the order flow coming in
you're not in this trade next bar after
that market trades Laura would have
stopped you out okay then sort of went
sideways before crapping out and selling
off you know wait for the complimentary
order flow to come in if it's not gonna
come in don't take the trade you know
here's another one you know all the
charts I'm showing you is just me now
it's a one-minute chart okay so I'm not
like picking ingre it's just over the
last two or three days so it's not like
I'm just picking and grabbing in certain
situations you know if these trades work
they work if they didn't they didn't but
I'm showing you how you could eliminate
trains like this one right you got the
nice down candle you know you got five
styling imbalances in the bar and big
you know open on your high close on your
low you know negative Delta you know
everything is bearish about this bar
okay don't get too excited yet
wait what happens in the next bar before
you get short you know if this next bar
starts coming in starts trading down I'd
be a lot more excited what do you got
well market turned up for one you got
positive Delta for two okay yeah I don't
have selling imbalances you don't have
buying and balances point of control is
you know it's that's lower but you know
part of the reason why it's lower is
because the bar is so short relative to
the previous bar okay you know that's
not a good trade to be in you know but
you're not going to be in it because
you're not seeing the order flow
complement in you know confirming what
you saw on the signal bar the next bar
higher your point of control positive
Delta again another small bar it's not
looking good
don't start thinking this markets just
gonna go sideways you know for the next
ten minutes and fall over no you expect
the market to make that move
you could have eliminated this trade
even though you have a signal this isn't
one of those trades you should have
stayed out of an order flow by just
waiting a little bit would have kept you
out of this trade right that's what you
want to do is you won't you don't want
to take the trades that are gonna just
go right up and stop you out right
that's not what you want to do at all
right here's another example okay you
got red candle down you know positive
Delta you know we've got some selling
imbalances three of them in there then
the next bar you can't even take out the
low of the signal bar that's your first
sign that this trade probably not gonna
work out if the market price action of
the next bar isn't confirming the order
flow of the previous bar then you see
higher point of control buying
imbalances positive Delta forget it you
know don't think almost sell it up here
and catch this pullback and come down
because what's gonna happen it's gonna
pull back and it's gonna keep pulling
back and it does before it just ends up
going sideways you know would have
stopped you out okay here's another
example okay and you got the nice big
wide-ranging bar giving you the sell
signal you got selling imbalances you
got a high point of control you got a
negative Delta you know it looks very
bearish next bar comes in it can't even
go lower than the low of the signal bar
then you start seeing buying imbalances
come in you start seeing positive Delta
this is one of those trades where you
know you used to tear say okay yeah look
I'm ready to get short I just need some
confirmation you know I want to see the
aggressive selling coming in because I
want to be short you know so I want to
be looking at negative Delta you know
you're not gonna really be too concerned
with the point of control right away
because it takes time to form the point
of control because you know that's the
point in the bar with the most volume so
it's just gonna hang around if the bar
closes but you're not seeing you know
you got one selling imbalance okay but
the market keeps ticking higher alright
that's not a good sign
right the next thing you know you're
taking out the height of that bar you
know if this is one of those trades that
kill the back of a lot of traders I got
cells thinking I like it short boom
same bar market stops them out yeah this
is what people you know they want to
punch their computer screen you know you
see these bars but what I'm saying is
you know you can just wait a little bit
let the market take you in right if
you're not seeing any flow coming in
that's negative right you want to be
short so you want see negative flow in
the sense of aggressive selling then
yeah you don't want to be in that
position you know so you could have
eliminated you could have stayed out of
this trade you could have stayed out of
that trade you could have stayed out of
this trade you know there's four trades
within the last couple days I could have
just taken off my desk completely you
know rather than get stopped out or give
up you know emotional capital on I could
have just passed on these trades not
taking them not worried about them
because you know I'm not seeing the
subsequent order flow coming in giving
me a sign to get short right now you
know here is a sell signal what happens
in the next bar you know you start
trading lower you take off the low you
put a lower point of control you got a
negative Delta right you got selling
imbalances this is what you want to see
all right this is the where you're gonna
be getting short you know on this bar
somewhere right compare this bar to this
bar this green candle right you don't
want to be getting short on a green on a
market that's that's going higher
because chances are it's gonna keep
going higher right an object in motion
it's gonna keep going in that direction
you know you do pull back a little bit
before you make that 20 tick move that
you're looking for but you know you
don't get anywhere really close to where
your stop is up here you know here's the
beautiful one beautiful buy signal all
right you got stick buying imbalances
you know you've got positive Delta
you're at your low next bar comes in
pulls back a little bit into the stack
buying a balance which is you know an
order flow
setup that you like to see you got a
higher point of control
you got that negative Delta okay you
know that's just something that's sort
of lingering got a question mark over
your head but then the next bar just
kills that three binding balances you
know higher high higher low positive
Delta strong positive Delta you know if
you weren't convinced in this bar the
second bar after you know the signal bar
by this the next bar you should be
loading up on this you know this is the
bar yeah I think it's markets going
higher you know and what happens it goes
sideways before making that 20-point
move that you're looking for yeah
another example right come down here you
got your buy signal market starts next
bar what happens positive Delta right
you got nice volume okay that's good you
got higher point of control higher high
higher low you've got you know the bar
closing above the high of that bar okay
fine I can get long now right you're not
getting long so far away from you know
the close of this bar you know I always
say with order flow you gotta wait for
the bars too close to confirm everything
but then you just wait just give it you
know a few more seconds before you take
the trade you don't identify that it's
working in your favor next bar comes in
yes it's yeah it's three price levels
right it's a doji candle opens and
closes where same level got negative
Delta okay you know it's not the end of
the world you know it's it's still a
good buy based on what happened right
after the signal bar I then boom the
aggressive buying comes in a nice strong
positive Delta you know a nice stack
buying imbalance you know and the market
just makes another 20-point move you
know everything is there in the order
flow in the next bar to tell you yeah
you have the follow-through order flow
coming into the market okay last one
here by signal next bar has confirming
price action you're close is higher now
again you know I'm always hesitant to
want to buy a new high but you know if
you're one of those breakout type
traders got the breakout you got a
higher point of control got positive
Delta bar closed higher you don't have
any buy
balances in there but you know you got
enough happening in the other parts of
order flow to want to be long and the
market boom makes new eyes makes new
eyes makes new eyes so again you know it
doesn't matter what method of trading
signals use define trades what you want
to do is monitor what's happening in the
market via the order flow before jumping
in right you don't just jump in both
hands say oh you know I got a buy signal
I got to get long no you know wait for
the order flow to come in to say hey now
it's the time to get long okay cuz
imagine you know look at this this is
just eight trades right you had four
winners for losers
every losing trade there's a reason to
not take that trade even though you had
a signal you know every trading system
gives you signals right you could even
just I sell at random but what happens
after you buy or sell in the order flow
is going to help you understand whether
the trade is going to be a winner or a
loser right don'ts don't jump into all
the trades thinking oh I gotta buy
signal I gotta buy I gotta buy you know
that's where people get burned you know
all those people have bought Bitcoin
kept going up I gotta buy I gotta buy
you know I don't know anybody now that
that's above water on any Bitcoin or
crypto currencies cuz you know they all
you know they didn't take a step back
and real read what was happening in the
market so hopefully by now you know you
can understand how using order flow is
going to help you put the pieces
together to improve your trading help
you you know stay out of bad trades or
get out of bad trades early rather than
taking the full stop you know honestly
you know it's we we love these trades as
soon as you get in it just goes in your
direction unfortunately a lot of times
there's many trades that just go
sideways on you or there's trades that
just immediately go against you right if
you could eliminate that imagine what
that's going to do for you mentally as a
trader as well as financially as a
trader it's going to reduce a lot of the
losing trades so again you know if
you're interested in order flows
you just go to my website order flows
calm I do have two specials I've got
this special which is the order flows
basic software which is order flows
trader 2.0 I call it for a ninja trader
8 this order flows calm slash off to to
to HTML if you want more indicators on
my website I got a special package there
now for those of you that are interested
in my book go to order flows calm slash
book dot HTML yeah make sure you put the
dot HTML on there and it's gonna take
you to this page you can see this is the
web browser you have to enter your name
and email address and hit submit once
you do you'll be taken to a link where
you can download it you're not gonna get
the actual coffee table book you're
gonna get the digital download so that
you can you know read it at your leisure
print it up you know read it in bed or
put it on your iPhone or your tablet or
read it at work you know it's the thing
is you know a lot of people don't
realize they get into trading they get
excited you know trading has been around
for many many years it's gonna be there
so you know get yourself up to speed on
what you need to know about trading and
understand what's happening in the
market you know there's a lot of great
software out there you got to learn how
to use it you gotta learn how to use
software to manage your trades you know
for me order flow makes really helps a
lot of traders see what's happening in
the market so let me just see if there's
any questions really quick there are
some questions um use one minute charts
well you could use whatever charts you
like you know you could use range based
charts you could use minute based rice
but order flow is best used on short
time frames you know don't really look
at anything above 10 minutes I don't 5
minutes is about as far out as I go you
know I'm a futures guy you know but I
know people that use it on stocks and
Forex but you know if you're gonna use
Forex I think your best that is open a
future
and trade the forex futures contracts
you know euro currency Japanese yen etc
okay Sally I'll get to you
and I think that's about it Anna I'll
throw it back to you Anna so have a
great day everyone